what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and a new DC event has emerged that has
fans well kind of confused but also kind
of really excited now of course we know
that the old dceu the old DC extended
universe is for the most part being
reset James Gunn has revealed his
chapter one or at least what he says is
a little less than half of his chapter
one slate titled Gods and Monsters he
gave us some movies and some projects
that were coming out and some fans are
excited some fans have mixed feelings
and of course some fans just do not like
it and a lot of people were really
hoping that the Snyder verse would
finally be restored and there's been a
lot of talk going around recently
stating that James Gunn is indeed going
to work with Zack Snyder again for his
new universe however there have also
been a lot of Insider stating no this is
a complete reboot Zack Snyder is not
going to be involved in this at all
which makes sense because James Gunn is
coming in with Peter saffron and they're
completely redoing everything basically
starting a new universe after the flash
but while all of this is happening Zack
Snyder himself has announced a big DC
Snyder verse event basically announcing
a Snyder con a big event that is
essentially going to focus on the
Justice League the Snyder cut version of
course and of course Batman vs Superman
and Man of Steel and fans have been
wondering since Zack Snyder teased this
announcement what exactly this means for
the future of DC well here's what today
Zack Snyder came out and told us about
it speaking on the nerd Queen's YouTube
Channel Zack Snyder gave us some details
about upcoming snydercon and the event
is really for a great cause it's going
to take place in Pasadena California
from April 28th to April 30th and it's
going to be a charity event that is
supposed to help raise money for the
American Foundation For Suicide
Prevention and the autumn Snyder tribute
fund which is a charity that is a
tribute to Zack Snyder's late daughter
who passed away so right away it's a
great meaningful event and if you did
love the Justice League that Zack Snyder
created and you have the means to go by
all means go check it out it should be a
lot of fun and it's for a good cause he
does go on to tell us a little bit more
about what to expect and the panels
they're going to be screening Man of
Steel on April 28th and do a panel
Batman vs Superman dawn of Justice April
29th and also do a panel about that but
then on the 30th they're going to be
screening Zack Snyder's Justice League
on the iMac screen at IMAX at Universal
CityWalk he also says that there is
going to be some exclusive merge that
you can never get before that's going to
be specifically made for this event and
there is going to be giveaways he said I
know there's some fan driven events
around the event whether it be giveaways
for some figures we're trying to get a
Batmobile I know there's a bunch of
stuff we're trying to get to also give
away in relation to this screenings so
it sounds like there's going to be some
pretty big giveaways speaking about the
merch he says the event itself of course
the screening event it's three nights
two at the art center and one at IMAX
then we're gonna have T-shirts that Jim
Lee is drawing us a t-shirt which is an
amazing design can't wait to show it
we're gonna have posters some of the
vendors that made us our posters for the
actual Justice League film itself have
been working on posters for the event we
have an additional Art Center poster
that we're making and as far as what to
expect from the panels here's what he
had to say for the man of steel panel he
said and then we're going to have a
panel after the Man of Steel screening
I'm working on the panel for Man of
Steel right now we'll see who and once I
sort of get people I'll hint at
individuals with any luck and then
Batman vs Superman we're gonna do the
movie then we're going to do a signing
I'll sign some posters and hopefully we
can talk about the movie a little bit
and a panel as well so this is going to
be a pretty big event for Zack Snyder's
Justice League films and the Snyder
verse fans but the question that
everybody has been asking will this
affect the new DC at all the answer
seems to be no he didn't mention the new
DC Universe at all as far as he is
involved with that is and this event
seems to be for charity of course but
also just for the fans for those who
wanted more of the Snyder verse more of
the Justice League that we have and for
those who want to see the Snyder vs
Justice League on big screen on IMAX and
I'm sure you can expect some of the big
names to show up I'm sure Henry cavill's
Superman is going to show up since sadly
he is no longer going to be in the new
DC Universe Ben Affleck's Batman might
show up we know that he's kind of got a
bad taste of DC right now especially
after he said that no he would not
direct any project for the new James
Gunn DC Universe so maybe Ben Affleck
shows up but we're not really counting
on him Jason Momoa he will probably show
up because he's always really thrilled
to do anything Aquaman related and right
now gal gadot's future is up in the air
it's very unclear right now they
canceled the third Wonder Woman movie
and basically James Gunn stated hey
we're still talking to GAO right now
about what we could possibly do in the
future but it has been confirmed that
there is not going to be a Wonder Woman
3 with Patty Jenkins and basically since
James Gunn stated well the heroes that
are a part of the Justice League in the
new universe they're going to be
starting over essentially and kind of
doing Origins not true origin stories a
different spin on them but he pretty
much confirmed that Superman the new
Superman is going to be much younger
than Henry Cavill Superman was in the
snyderverse so it's a big mystery right
now if Gal Gadot is going to be showing
up anywhere in the new DC Universe as
Wonder Woman there is a chance because
the Multiverse is going to be a thing
but they probably will cast a newer
younger Wonder Woman for their Wonder
Woman projects that seems to be the case
for most of what is going on in the new
DC Universe but as long as something
doesn't really interfere with the plan
that James Gunn and Peter Safran have
they are still open to whatever might
come along Shazam 2 Fury of the Gods and
the character in general Shazam is a
good example now Zachary Levi has stated
that he wants the character to continue
on in the new DC Universe even if it
isn't him playing the actor but he did
also state that he did talk to Peter
Safran about the future of Shazam and
himself in the new DC Universe this is
what he had to say about it
listen I've talked to Peter a good bit
we're gonna talk more on this tour
certainly the idea is to continue the
character this world it's a really
enjoyable extension of the DCU it has
DNA that a lot of other characters and
extensions don't necessarily have
because we are a more family movie that
kind of franchise comes with a lot of
fun and he finished by stating this what
they've said is that what we've done in
these two Shazam movies doesn't
contradict anything they're doing with
their new plans which is great it means
that you could do Shazam movies if you
wanted to we'll see how that all works
out now James Gunn is pretty much
rebooting almost everything although
some things are unclear like how Jason
momoa's Aquaman is going to stick around
and if galgo does Wonder Woman sticks
around how exactly is that going to work
we don't really know at this point in
time and James Gunn probably doesn't
exactly know either which is why he has
stated we are talking about it so keep
your hopes up that some of these
characters might return in some way
perhaps via the Multiverse but in the
meantime if you did enjoy the old
Justice League the old Snyder verse
films this snydercon is a great fun
event that you can attend if you are
close enough or if you feel like
traveling you could feel some Nostalgia
watch these movies on the big screen
watch the Snyder cut on IMAX and support
a really good charity let us know in the
comments down below if you wanted the
snyderverse to be restored or if you're
okay with the new plans that James Gunn
and Peter saffron have for the new DCU
let us know down below and of course
please be sure to like the video and
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
all of the latest DC news you can always
follow us on Instagram and Twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof